now let's turn to a disturbing scene out
of Portland Oregon once again violent
protests erupting over the weekend look
at your screen screen chaos descending
on parts of the city of Portland and
Tifa clashing with members of these you
know fringe nationalist white
supremacist bigoted groups to each and
every single person on either side that
has an extreme agenda I want all of you
you must stop this insanity this
lawlessness police need to stop this and
end it and drop it right when it starts
this kind of behavior is unacceptable
it's insane it's despicable it's
violence it's extremism and it's hurting
our country well let's not forget we can
have political disagreements but at the
end of the day we're all Americans
remember we're all created equal we're
all one nation under God and in the
United States political differences we
solve them at the ballot box long as
there's no cheating or Hilary buying of
course Russian lies and trying to pawn
them off as truth that's a problem or
people abusing their power but what
matters here is we can have a thorough
complete passionate open discussion of
ideas and ideals we don't need fists and
baseball bats and mace now this show
will always condemn hatred on any side
white supremacy bigotry you have no
place in this society
none whatsoever people chanting what do
we want dead cops when do we want them
now you we you are radicals and you're
hurting our country and you're putting
the men and women that protect and serve
us at risk your auntie for extremists
the same goes to you what do they have
in common they're all tied to sick ugly
twisted evil ideologies we've got to
remain one United States this is a
country of God's greatest gift to man
created equal
God's natural rights of life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness that's a gift
for all of us all American citizens